[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
حسن جمول
وفي الوقت الذي يحدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعلوا اخرى العمل
في كابول قتله وجرحى في تفجير عند مدخل
المطار العسكري للعاصمه الافغانيه لم تعلن
على الفور اي جهه
مسؤوليتها عن العمل
من برازيليه تصلنا هذه الصور ناسيو لولا
دا سيلفا يؤدي اليمين الدستوريه رئيسا
جديدا للبرازيل بعد انتخابات اكتوبر
الماضي
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
بسبب حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا لندن تنهي
رسميا استيراد الغاز الروسي المسان موسكو
تفرض تعامله بالروبل في المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطراتها في شرق اوكرانيا وجنوبها
وصندوق النقد الدوليه
الاتحاد الاوروبي قد تدخل مرحله ركود
اقتصاديا هذا العام
[موسيقى]
ميدانيا روسيا تولين تدمير طائرات
اوكرانيه
لقصف اراضيها
وكاميرا الجزيره ترصد تصدي الجيش
الاوكراني لهجمات الروسيه شماليه
واستعادته مدنا وبلدات في المقاطعه
في تصعيد جديد ضد جارتها الجنوبيه كوريا
الشماليه تواصل اطلاق صواريخ بالستيه شرقا
و زعيمها يامر بتطوير مزيد من الصواريخ
لسنه هجمات النوويه مضاده
وصول تهدد برد قوي وحاسا على اي استفزاز
وتحذر من تقويض السلم في المنطقه
في تفجير جديد في العاصمه الافغانيه 14
قتيلا وثمانيه عشر مصابا في هجوم
الانتحاريه على المطار العسكري في كابول
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اعلان رئيسي مجلس السياده
السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان انه يتطلع
لتوسيع قاعده التوافق السياسيه حتى يمه
هذا الطريق لخطوات اخرى اكثر اهميه
جدد البرهان التزام المؤسسه العسكريه
بالخروج نهائيا من العمليه السياسيه كما
حذر مما سماه اقصاء الاخرين وتقديم دورهم
وعدم الاستماع الى مطالبهم وفرض الوصايا
من فئه محدده من قطاعات الشعب
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال الثالث ما هي افاق المشهد
السوداني في العام الجديد مع احتمال توسيع
قاعده التوافق والوعد لخروج العسكر من
العمليه السياسيه
17% توقعوا تحقيقه تقدم بينما توقع
33% مزيدا تعقيده في المشهد ورجح 50%
استمرار الوضع الحالي
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه
يتجدد يوميا وان التطرق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
[تصفيق]
اليسا
يعود الى السلطه في البرازيل بعد سجل
سياسيا وقانوني وتجربه في السجن
[موسيقى]
في اليوم الاول من العام الجديد اعلنت
الخارجيه البريطانيه وقف جميع واردات
الغاز الطبيعي الموسال من روسيا اعتبارا
من اليوم وقالت الخارجيه البريطانيه انها
بهذا القرار تطلع عن الرئيس الروسي لازم
احد مصادر تمويل حربه في اوكرانيا داعيه
دول العالم الى خفض اعتمادها على الغزل
الروسيه وتظهر البيانات الحكوميه ان
المملكه المتحده استوردت مقيمته
مليونا جنيه استرليني من النفط من روسيا
في الاشهر السبعه التي عقدت بدل الحرب
لكنها لم تستورد الفحم او الغاز وفي عام
2021 زودت روسيا المملكه المتحده باربعه
بالمئه من احتياجاتها من الغاز وتسعه
بالمئه من احتياجاتها النفسيه وسبعه
وعشرين بالمئه من الفحم بقيمه الاجماليه
قدرها اربعه مليارات ونصف المليار جنيه
استرليني
على صعيد اخر قالت مديره صندوق النقد
الدولي كريستالينا جورجيبا ان الاتحاد
الاوروبيه تضرر اقتصاديا بشده بسبب الحرب
في اوكرانيا واضافت جورجي جيفا في حديث
لشبكه سي بي اس الامريكيه ان الصندوق
يتوقع ان تدخل نصف دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
في حاله ركود خلال العام الجديد
في العام الجديد كذلك الصين ستتراضى
وسيكون العام الجديد صعبا عليها هذا كله
سيرجم الى اتجاهات سلبيه على مستوى العالم
وعندما ننظر الى الاسواق الناشئه ولا
اقتصادات الناميه ستكون الصوره رهيبه فتلك
الاقتصادات تتاثر باسعار الفائده المرتفعه
وارتفاع قيمه الدولار
ذلك سيكون الامر بالنسبه للاقتصادات التي
لديها مستويات عاليه من الديون بمثابه
الدمار
وفي اليوم الاول من عام 2023 بدات
المقاطعه الاوكرانيه التي سبق انضمتها
روسيا قبل نحوي ثلاثه اشهر العمل بالقرار
الصادر عن الادارات المحليه المواليه
لموسكو بالتوقف عن تداول العمله
الاوكرانيه واقتصاد التداوله هناك على
الروبل الروسي ما الذي يعنيه هذا القرار
وكيف ستكون انعكاساته
منذ اليوم الراجل الروسي والعمله الوحيده
التي سيتم تداولها في المقاطعه الاوكرانيه
التي سبق وانضمتها موسكو اليها والتوقف عن
تداول العمله الاوكرانيه الهريبنا القرار
يشمل المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره روسيا في
مقاطعه اقليم دون باس دنيا
وخرسان من شان هذا القرار ترسيخ السياده
الروسيه على تلك المقاطعات اذ ياتي ايضا
بعد قرارات اخرى تتعلق بمنح الجنسيه
الروسيه لسكانيه تلك المناطق واعتماد
الاسماء الروسيه لمدنها وبلداتها بدلا من
الاوكرانيه وتغيير رمز الاتصال الدولي لها
على الصعيد الاقتصاديين انتظروا ان يساهم
القرار في تخفيف الاثار المتعلقه بالعقبات
الغربي من خلال توسيع التداول بالروبلبل
ومن شانه ان يؤدي الى تخفيض نسب التضخم
واستقرار قيمه العمله فضلا انه سيسرع من
عمليه دمج النشاط الاقتصادي والعمليات
الماليه في تلك المناطق في بنيه الاقتصاد
الروسي تعود اصول الروبل الروسي الى القرن
الثالث عشر حين تم استعماله كلمه روبل
لاول مره في اماره نوفاغورد احدى مدن
الشمال الغربي لروسيا للدلاله على السبائك
المصنوعه من الفضه
[موسيقى]
ميدانيا لن يمهل العام الجديد في يومه
الاول طرفي حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وقتا
لالتقاط انفاسهما فقد استيقظ اكتيفوها
مناطق اخرى في انحاء البلاد على واقع
انفجارات وهجمات روسيه اتهمت وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه موسكو لانها نفذت عددا منها
بمسيرات ايرانيه الصنع تطورات لاحت معها
اسئله بشان مسار الحرب وميزانها وهي تقترب
من طي عامها الاول خلال رضعه اسابيع
حل عام جديد ومع يومه الاول هجمات روسيه
بعشره المسيرات الايرانيه الصنع وفقايات
استهدفت مقاطعه عده هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه قالت ان القوات الروسيه خلال
24 ساعه استادفت البلاد ب 31 صاروخا و 12
ضربه جويه واكثر من 70 قذيفه كافه اهتزت
هي ومدن اخرى في انحاء البلاد على وقع في
جرارات وتحدث الجيش الاوكراني عن اسقاط
دفاعاته 45 مسيرتا قال انها ايرانيه الصنع
بينها 30 وكوستاني
وفي ما يبدو ردا على التصريحات الاوكرانيه
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الصواريخها
الدقيقه بعيده المدى استهدفت امس ما صنع
عسكريه اوكرانيه تستخدم لانتاج المسارات
الهجوميه بتت مواقع عسكريه روسيه صورا
قالت انها لقصف صاروخيه استهدف قاعده
للقوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
اخبرنيسيسكي وتحدثت عن ان الامر يتعلق
بالفوج الثامن الذي يعد الافضل بين القوه
الخاصه الاوكرانيه عسكريه ايضا قال رئيس
مديريه الاستخبارات في وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه انه لا يزال لدى روسيا
احتياطيه صاروخيه كافيه لشم هجومين او
ثلاثه واسعه النطاق مستقبلا على عموم
اوكرانيا واضاف ان روسيا يمكنها انتاج مما
يصل الى 50 صاروخان من نوع شهريا وان اي
هجوم روسي كبير سيحتاج الى نحو شهر ونصف
لانتاج الصواريخ جديده تطورات تاتي بينما
اكدت الاستخاره الاوكرانيه شهر مارس اداري
المقبل سيكون صعبا على روسيا من ناحيه نقص
العدد والذخيره مضيفه ان النصر الاوكراني
يتمتله في استعاده حدود اوكرانيا التي
رسمت عام 91 بما فيها شبه جزيره القرم
[موسيقى]
ينظم
مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيا السابق ومن
موسكو العقيد فيكتور
محرر الشؤون العسكريه في وكاله
تاسس الروسيه
[موسيقى]
ما الذي يجري عمليا الان غير القصف والقذف
المتبادل اين تكمن الجبهات الابرز وما
الذي تسعى لتحقيقه اوكرانيا عسكريا في
الوقت الحاضر
الكثير من ما حدث في الايام الاخيره خاصه
والهجمات بالمسيرات على البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه
الاوكرانيه وهذا مؤشر الى ان روسيا
لا تستطيع ان تصل الى اي نتائج حقيقيه في
ارض المعركه
ان المهمه الاهم في اوكرانيا هي الحفاظ
على المبادره
وتجهيز القوه
للوقوف ضد اي هجمات او تقدم روسي
استرجاع في تلك المناطق حيث سيكون هناك
مجالات للهجوم الاوكراني سنقوم بهذا يعني
الهدف الان هو فقط محاوله منع تقدم
للقوات الروسيه على الجبهات سيد فيكتور
بالنسبه لموسكو الان هي تركز على عمليات
القصف وفقط عمليات القسم من دون اي تحركات
همم ميدانيه في اي سياق يندرج هذا الامر
كذلك نحن بالطبع نقوم بضرابات على الخطوط
الخلفيه للقوات الاوكرانيه ونقصف المنشات
للطاقه التي
تتواصل بين شبكات الاتصالات والنقل
ونقصف محطات
القطارات الحديديه حتى ااه حتى ندمر
القدرات العسكريه لنقل الذخيره والمعدات
وفي نفس الوقت نحن همم صد الهجمات في
كريسماس الايمان ودخلنا الى ماسك هناك
معارك في شوارع اركان
التي يسموها بخموت في اوكرانيا سوف تحرر
وهذا يعني اننا نفتح الطريق
واحنا نصدها جمال العدو الاوكراني
ومحاولته في التقدم وفي ضوا ايضا نحن لا
نتوقف على ضربات الصاروخيه نحن نقوم بقصف
المسيرات الاوكرانيه وندمر الطائرات
والهليكوبترات همم الاوكرانيه اذا ظهرت في
السماء اعتقد ان هذه مهمات مجتمعه تقوم
بهاء القوات الروسيه
تتحدث عن محاوله فتح الطريق الى اكراماتوس
امام القوات الروسيه سيد اوليكس هنا في
المقابل القوات الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن
استعادتها همم السيطره على العديد من
البلدات في دنياك في حين ان ضيفنا يتحدث
عن همم تقدم في ضخموت وامكانيه فتح الطريق
الى الكراماتوس
كيف يمكن ان نفهم هذا تناقض
الو
اقول انه بالفعل
في
الاسابيع السابقه الاخيره كان هناك
استقرار في خطوط التواجه وهذا بسبب
الاجواء الطقسيه
والطرفين لديهم نقص في الذخيره والمد سواء
كان في القوات العسكريه او في الذخيره اما
بالنسبه
عند القوه الروسيه اعتقد ان ان هناك
مبالغه في هذا الامر لانه عمليه منذ شهر
يقول لم يكون هناك اي نجاح عسكري للقوات
الروسيه وروسيا الان هي في وضع الدفاع
الشديد
الاجباري هو حيث يحققون بعض الهجمات
الاستراتيجيه البسيطه هذا يحدث
بعد خساره في الجنود كبير كبيره جدا
وروسيا التطبيقيه لا تتمكن من اي شيء في
اقرب فرصه ممكنه سوف يكون
هناك محاولات من الطرفين للقيام بهامات
محوريه
طيب هل لديك اي
تعليق على همم دخول القرار قرار استخدام
العمله الروسيه في المناطق التي ضمتها
روسيا وهمم تقع تحت سيطره قواتها الان في
في اوكرانيا هل لديك تعليق هذا القرار
كانت اخذ سابقا لكن دخلت حيز التنفيذ مع
بدايه هذا اليوم العام الجديد
هذا
القوات المحتله ان تقوم بادخال عملتها
الخاصه ولكن المعلومات التي لدينا هناك
الكثير من المعلومات تتحدث عن ان سكان
يقفون ضدها هذه المعاملات وفي الاماكن
التي تم
تحريرها منذ شهر لم يستطيع العدو ان يفرض
اي من اجراءاته او عملته ان الاوكران
يقفون ضد هذه الاجراءات لانهم لا يريدون
التحول للعمله الروسيه همم
هنا اسال ضيفنا من من موسكو الى اي مدى
تتوقع لهذا القرار سيد في دكتور ان همم
قبولا شعبيا ولا يكون هناك مقاومه لاحقه
لقرار استخدام الروبل
برنس
تقريبا ان السكان
ايضا لكن عندما خرجت القوات الروسيه من
كرتون الكثير من السكان استقبلوا القوات
الاوكرانيه بساعده لان المخابرات
الاوكرانيه تقوم باعدام كل من تعاون مع
القوات الروسيه
عجيب او غريب في ان ال- سكان يستقبلون
بالسعاده القوات الروسيه ثم يفرحون
باستقبال القوات الاوكرانيه هنا يجب ان
اقول ان القوه الروسيه خرجت
بنفسها بقرار خاصه من خرطون لتقليل
الضحايا واخرجت معها الكثير من السكان
المدنيين حتى لا يتعرضوا للخطر لانه كان
من الصعب ان نقوم بمجد السكان خلال عن
طريق النهر بالمعاونه الانسانيه ولم نخسر
اي شيء في خرسون لا قد غيرنا الموقع الى
موقع اخر اما بالنسبه
للدعم والمد واا المد بالعساكر نعم
التعبئه بدات تتوجه
للجبهات وهذا يثبت انه في المستقبل سوف
يكون هو جاء هجمات حقيقيه وعلى الجيش
الاوكراني ان يستعد لهذا ذلك وبالمناسبه
الكثير من القوات الاوكرانيه تقتل في
الاسابيع الاخيره همم في كرسنا وفي نعم
وفي وفي
قتل حوالي 200 جندي
العشرات من المعدات تدمر
الدين
العسكريه في وكاله الروسيه من موسكو شكرا
لالكسي مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيا
السابق
تسعى القوه الاوكرانيه الى حمايه المدن
والبلدات التي استعادتها من سيطره القوات
الروسيه لتشجيع السكان على العوده الى تلك
المناطق لكن هذه المدن والبلدات تشكو من
غياب ابرز الخدمات الاساسيه وهو ما دفع
السكان للتعايش مع ظروف قاسيه
في الجبهات الشماليه من مقاطعه دنياك
تستعين القوات الاوكرانيه بمدافع روسيه
الصنع لنشرها في المناطق القريبه من
البلدات التي استرجعتها مؤخرا
تسع هذه الوحدات كما يقول القاده
الميدانيون الى الحاق الضرر بالقوات
الروسيه واستهداف مخازن الاسلحه وخطوط
الامداد وتشكيل خط راضع لاي محاولات
لاسترجاعها
الان لا نتصدى للهجمات بل نحرص على الالات
ساهم في عوده الناس الى مدننهم
[تصفيق]
تشمل هذه النقاط مدينتي لمن وصفته ريسك
اللتين استعادهما الجيش الاوكراني اواخر
سبتمبر ماضي
يقول الجيش الاوكراني انه يتصدى لهجمات
الجيش الروسي في محاور ويسترجع مدنا
فما هو حال المدن والبلدات المسترجعه في
ظل ظروف الشتاء هذه السيده ذات السبعين
عاما بقيت في مدينه اليمن اكبر الحواضر
المسترجعه مؤخرا
اوه تموت انستالي
لكن التدفئه والمياه متوقفتان لك ان تتخيل
المعاناه مع البرد القارس تساعدنا الحكومه
في تقديم بعض الفحم لكن علينا جمع الحطب
من الغابه بانفسنا اعيش مع زوجي على راتب
التقاعد فقط لكن لا خيار لابد للحياه ان
تستمر
مفاتيح بيوتهم لترعاها في غيابهم
ولتستمر الحياه حفرت بئرا للحصول على
الماء فالحرب لم تترك لها خيارات كثيره
يشهد الدمار الكبير على براوه المعارك
التي جرت في المدينه ومع ذلك يقيم فيها
عدد لا باس به من السكان
عوده الناس الى هنا بالرغم من صعوبه
الظروف
كشفت كذلك عن مساوئ اخرى للحرب
في ما يعاني اخرون فقرا وفاقا سيحتاج
التخلص
لمواصله القتال عمر الحاجه الجزيره من
مدينه اليمن
تسلم وزراء حكومه اليمين المتطرف في
اسرائيل برئاسه بنيامين نتنياهو حقائبهم
الوزاريه في الحكومه المنتهيه ولايتها
برئاسه
جرى تسليم المهام دون طقوس المعهوده في
اغلب الوزارات حيث فضل كثيرون الاكتفاء
بلقاء مجامله سريع بد ان زعيم حزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه المتطرفه كثير الذي
تسلم حقيبه الامن الداخلي بعد ما تم
تحويلها الى وزاره الامن القومي استقبل
بحارس شرف وتبادل مع سلف عمير برليف
[موسيقى]
وكان رئيس الوزراء الايطالي قد قال ان
الالتزام الاول لحكومه هو احباط مساعي
ايران للحصول على سلاح النووي وفق تعبيره
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الايراني والمدير
العام لدائره شؤون الخليجيه في الخارجيه
الايرانيه مرحبا بك سيد علي اذا نتنياهو
عاد الى السلطه حكومه هي الاكثر تطرفا كما
توصف والاكثر يمينيه في اسرائيل
والبرنامج او البند الاول في برنامج
نتنياهو اا السعي لمنع حصول ايران على
سلاح النووي كيف ستتعامل طهران مع هذا
التطور
السلام عليكم وعلى مشاهديكم مشاهد
مشاهدينا الكرام ااا
طبعا ايران لا تبحث عن
السلاح النووي حتى ياتي احدا ويتكلم عنه
ملف ايران النووي واضح جدا
فدخلت ايران في مفاوضات جاده مع مجموعه
خمسه زائد واحد سابقا
واربعه زائد واحد لاحقا في همم في الدفاع
عن حقه المشروع
للاستخدام او همم
تكنولوجيا للطاقه الذريه وهذا الملف واضح
بشهاده الوكاله الدولي للطاقه الذريه
وايران هي مبتعده عن همم عن الحديث عن
السلاح النووي فا- همم
اتصور لا يوجد مجال في الحديث عن هذا
الامر هل تستشعرون خطرا من اسرائيل
وسبق ان كانت هناك تهديدات ربما حتى
بمحاوله ااه ضرب اهداف داخل ايران من قبل
اسرائيل
اااه نسمع بين حين واخر مثل هذه التهديدات
ايران ليست همم طلقه من هذه التهديدات وفي
نفس الوقت همم هي جاهزه للرد على اي
اعتداء ايران همم همم تتحدث همم بلغه
السلام ولا تلتفت الى مثل هذه التهديدات
طب اذا اردنا ان نستغل وجودك لا السؤال عن
بعض القضايا المتعلقه بامن ال- اا المنطقه
ايضا كان هناك مؤتمر شارك فيه وزير
الخارجيه لايراني في منطقه البحر الميت
مؤتمر بشان الامن الاقليمي بشان العراق
تحديدا ما الذي خرجت منه ايران ب همم هذا
المؤتمر او من هذا المؤتمر
حضرنا المؤتمر في دورتيه بغداد ال
اول وبغداد الثاني في العراق وفي الاردن
وايران كانت حاضره في هاتين الدورتين
واكد واقول بان ايران دائما كانت حاضره
وجاهزه في دعم العراق قبل هذا المؤتمر
وقلنا مرارا بان ايران مع العراق قبل
المؤتمر حين المؤتمر وبعد المؤتمر اما همم
كيف همم همم
تعاملت ايران مع
المؤتمر في الجانب همم
السياسي نحن اكلنا دعمنا للعمليه السياسيه
في العراق
وكنا بجانب العراق في هذه العمليه العراق
الجديد المبني على اراده همم الشعب العراق
في المؤتمر الذين شاردتهم الى جانب جانبهم
في هذا المؤتمر يرون بان ايران جزء من
المشكله في العراق
وليست جزءا همم من الحل او بمعنى اخر هي
همم جزء من الخلاف القائم داخل المكونات
العراقيه ووجودها بشكل او باخر في العراق
هو مشكله بالنسبه اليهم
طبعا انا كنت يعني من ضمن المشاركين في
مؤتمر بغداد الاول والمؤتمر بغداد الثاني
للتعاون
والشراكه وانا لم اسمع مثل هذه العبارات
في
الكلمات التي القيت وحقيقه انا اريد ان
همم
اشيد بمثل هذا المؤتمر الذي جمع فيه
كثيرون في الاجتماع الاخير 12 12 دوله ااه
وكل هذه الدول تحدثت بلغه همم
الحوار والمشاركه والمساعده ولم يتحدث احد
في همم هذه
الندوات او في هذا المنتدى همم في توجيه
الاتهام الى الطرف الاخر واا نحن نحبز مثل
همم هذه المنتديات التي بنيت على اضافه
الحوار ودون ان نتتهم همم الطرف الاخر او
الطرف الاخر يتهم الطرف الثاني ففي
الحقيقه يجلس
المشاركون والمجتمعون ويتحدثون عن موضوع
واحد وطبعا العراق في
هذا همم في هذه في هذا المنتدى كانت نقطه
الالتقاء النقطه دي التقاء الجميع والجميع
عبروا عن رؤاهم
وفكرتهم تجاه العراق مثل ما تحدث في
الجانب السياسي وفي الجانب الاقتصادي وفي
الجانب الامني وحقيقه كل المشاركين همم
تكلموا عن امن العراق وايضا نحن في خطاب
او في كلمه معالي الوزير الايراني اكد بان
الحوار والتعاون هو ليس انتخابا بل ضروره
لهذا الاقليم
سيره كدنا مع الجميع لاستبباب الامر على
على سيره
اللقاءات التي حصلت ايضا
والنقاشات كان هناك لقاء لافذ بين وزيري
الخارجيه الايراني والسعودي على هامش هذا
المؤتمر
على ما تم الاتفاق وما الذي تم بحثه في
هذا اللقاء
همم طبعا همم مثل ما ذكرتهم يعني
الهوامش في بعض الاحيان يعني همم مهمه
ايضا في هامش اللقاء كان همم
سلحت الفرصه اللي همم
حوار الودي الودي بين وزير خارجيه ايران
وزير خارجيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وتحدث لجانبان عن رؤاهم تجاه همم الجولات
السابقه في الحوار اللي تمت في بغداد وانا
اغتنم الفرصه واشكر اخواننا العراقيين ل-
همم دورهم البناء في هذا المجال لتقريبه
وجهاد نظر
الايرانيين والسعوديين وهمم عبر عبر
الطرفان ارتياحهم اللي همم هذه الجولات
واعلن
استعداداهما للمضي قدما واتخاذ خطوات اخرى
في
لاحقا نحن حقيقه
نرى
الحوار بحذا ذاته مفيد جدا
وحقيقه ثمار هذا الحوار ايضا مهم لكن نحن
في الخطوات الاولى همم لا نسرع ولا نبطئ
نريد ان نصل الى النتيجه وكلنا نعلم بان
العلاقات همم
علاقات ايران مع جيرانها لا تتميز
بالانتقائيه ونحن نريد العلاقات الحسنه بل
الممتازه مع جميع جيراننا نحن لها
العلاقات الطيبه مع دوله قطر
وبالمناسبه نهنئكم ونهنئ دوله قطر بمناسبه
كاس العالم
وهذا هو يعتبر نجاح لجميع ابناءنا في
الاقليم ولجميع الدول الاسلاميه والعربيه
وهمم الدول الاقليميه همم بين القوسين
العلاقات الطيبه مع السلطنه علاقت طيبه مع
مع الكويت واكيد المشاهدون يعرفون بان همم
نحن همم طوال السنه الفائته والتي
تبلورت بشعار همم الاولويه للجيران همم في
الحقيقه رجع همم سفير الكويتي والسفير
الاماراتي الى الى ايران ونحن مع السعوديه
دون الانتقائيه ان- ننظر الى اعاده
العلاقات الباب من جهتنا مفتوحه مثل ما
سمعنا من وزير خارجيه السعوديه حيث قال
همم ايادينا ممدوده ونحن نشد على هذه
الايادي الممدوده
طيب ايه
هل حدد موعد
لقاء جديد في العراق في بغداد
لقاء
سعودي ايراني برعايه عراقيه باختصار
حتى الان لم يحدث
حتى الان لم يحدد طيب اشرت الى ان الباب
مفتوح
للعلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع مع السعوديه
ما المانع من
عوده هذه العلاقات ما هي الموانع التي
مازالت متبقيه علما ان انه كانت هناك
العديد من جولات الحوار التي حصلت في
العراق بين الجانبين
نعم كما ذكرتهم خمس جولات في العراق
ونحن في تلك يعني الجولات ااا احرزنا بعض
بعض التقدم في مجالات عده ومنها طبعا
حج
السنه
الحاليه وفي الحقيقه الايرانيون
راحوا الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ورجعوا باطمئنان همم
بالنسبه الى الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايراني
لا يوجد اي مانع في الحقيقه نحن مثل ما
قلنا همم
الابواب مفتوحه والامر بالنسبه الى اعاده
العلاقات يعود الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه نحن من جهتنا
مستعدون همم مثل هذه العلاقات والتي راح
تكون باذن الله طيبه وطبعا همم العلاقات
الايرانيه السعوديه اثر للظروف الاقليميه
ونحنوه ندرك هذا الامر ولذلك ك- اا لا
ظاهر يعني بالنسبه للجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه همم
اود بعض اجوبه باختصار سيد علي هل انتم
مستعدون وانت اشرت الى استعداد ايران
لعلاقات طيبه مع دول مع جيرانها تحديدا مع
دول الخليج هل انتم مستعدون لابرام
لاتفاقيات امنيه وسياسيه همم مع دول
الخليج كامله باختصار
لعلمكم نحن قمنا ببيته همم على اتفاقيه
امنيه مع بعض الدول في خليج فارس مثل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وسلطنه عمان ولا
يمنع بان توقع على اتفاقيات اخرى مع الدول
الاخرى وكذلك نحن مستعدون ل- همم اجتماع
اقليمي مثل ما اشار اليه الوزير الايراني
في منتدى طهران لوزراه خارجيه وزاره
الدفاع التعاون والعراق وايران وسوان في
الاتفاقات الثنائيه او الاتفاقات الجماعيه
ايران هي مستهده لذلك همم
اللافته بعض الدول الخليجيه هنا تلعب دورا
في محاوله تقريب وجوهات النظر بين ايران
والولايات المتحده للعوده الى الاتفاق همم
النووي هل هذه الجهود
ما زالت مستمره في ضوء المواقف التي
سمعناها مؤخرا من الجانب الامريكي وحتى
ايضا من الجانب الايراني
طبعا هناك جهود من عده دول ومنها دوله قطر
الشقيقه وسلطنه عمان الشقيقه والعراق
الشقيق ونحن نرحب مثل هذه الادوار ايران
ما وقفها بالنسبه الى الملف النووي واضح
جدا نحن مع الاتفاق نريده هذا الاتفاق لكن
الطرف الاخر قد يرى الاوراق ايران يريد ان
تريد ان تكون همم هذا الاتفاق يضمن همم
مصالحها المشروعه في الاتفاق النووي وكذلك
همم ترفع العقوبات الظالمه ال- الجهود ما
زالت مستمره حتى اللحظه
الجهود لا تزال مستمره هل هل لدى ايران اي
خطه بديله في ملوي لم تنجح هذه الجهود خطه
بي كما يقال
طبعا ايران مع يعني سيناريو الف او فلان
ايه ولكن الوزير الايراني مع الوزير
الايراني دكتور رامي العبدليان اكد قبل
ايام بان هذا الباب ليس مفتوحا الى الابد
لكن ايران تفضل سيناريو الف
واتصور حسب ما افهم سيناريو الف مقابل الف
ولو لا سمح الله سيناريو بي مقابل سيناري
نتحدث عن الحوارات همم هل هناك هل تلقيتهم
اي دعوه
لدعوه عراقيه ربما
لحوار مع مصر حوار ايراني مصري مثلا على
غرار الحوار ال- ال- الايراني السعودي في
بغداد
حقيقه ااه نحن نرحب
بالدور العراق الاقليمي البناء في جميع
الاخوه العراقيون سوان اكان في العلاقات
الايرانيه السعوديه او المصريه الايرانيه
او الاردنيه الايرانيه وهناك حديث من
سمعناه ومن اخواننا العراقيين بان هذا هو
مطلوب وكان همم تعرفون بان مكتب رعايه
مصالح المصريه همم همم
موجود مفتوح يعني في في طهران ويقوم
بنشاطاته كما ان قائم بالاعمال الاردنيه
المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه موجود بطهران
ويقوم من نشاطاته وحقيقه في
لقائنا مع
همم ملك عبد الله ملك الاردن تم الحديث عن
همم
افاق للعلاقات الايرانيه الاردنيه ولا
ظاهر كما قلت يعني بالنسبه مصر همم
جمهوريه مصر العربيه ايران هي مستعده لذلك
ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لك علي رضا عنايه مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الايراني والمدير العام لدائره
شؤون الخليجيه في الخارجيه الايرانيه
حدثتنا من طهران
[موسيقى]
في شبه جزيره الكوريه تعهد زعيم كوريا
الشماليه
بلاده العسكريه وزياده انتاجها من الرؤوس
النوويه والصواريخ بما يمكنها من تنفيذ
ضربات النوويه مضاده على حد قوله في
المقابل قال وزير الدفاع الكوريه الجنوبي
انا رد بلاده سيكون قويا وحاسما على اي
استفزاز مباشر
للاسلحه النوويه يهدف الى تدمير السلام
وان اي استخدام من تلك الاسلحه سيؤدي الى
نهايه نظامي
بالعام الجديد الا ان يحمل لشبه الجزيره
الكوريه مزيدا من السيناريوهات القادمه
الدفاعيه لعام 2023
استراتيجيه تقوم على تعزيز القوه العسكريه
بشكل عام لكنها تستند بالاساس الى الردع
النووي ردا على ما سماها السياسات
العدائيه المتبعه من قبل الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه
طال بكين بزياده هائله في التراسنه
النوويه بما فيها الرؤوس التكتيكيه
والصواريخ البالستيه العابره للقارات كما
دعا الى تطوير خطط لاطلاق قمر صناعي
للتجسس الى الفضاء في اسرع وقت ممكن
ارد كوريا الجنوبيه جاء سريعا بانعقاد
اجتماع طارئ ضم القاده السياسيين
والعسكريين ولاحقا حذر وزير الدفاع في سول
من ان بلاده سترد بقوه دون تردد على اي
استفزاز مباشر من الشطر الشمالي وان الجيش
سيطور قدراته لردعه تلك المخاطر
وبلغت تهديدات ذروتها باعلان الوزير
الكوري الجنوبي ان اي استخدام للسلاح
النووي من بيونغيانج سيعني حتما نهايه
نظام كيم جونغ اون
جاءت هذه التطورات على وقع ضجيج التجارب
الصاروخيه المستمره فبعد اطلاقها ثلاثه
صواريخ يوم السبت اطلقت كوريا الشماليه
ليله السبت الاحد صاروخا بالسيا اخر
باتجاه بحر اليابان المعروف ايضا باسم
البحر الشرقي
الشماليه
نحو 70 صاروخا ينظر اليها على انها رسائل
وغضب من التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه في
المنطقه من جانب الولايات المتحده
وحالفاتها كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
والتوتر قد يبلغ ذروته في العام الجديد
حيث لم يترك الزعيم الكوري الشمالي اي
مجال تقريبا للعوده الى محادثات نزع
السلاح المتعثر منذ زمن طويل مع الشطر
الجنوبي بل فمتى من المراقبين من راى في
هذا التصعيد انذارا باحتمال ان تصبح شبه
الجزيره الكوريه اوكرانيا ثانيه اذا ما
ادرت الازمه بشكل سيء
جوليو بوليسيه استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
المختص بشؤون الاسيويه في جامعه اكسفورد
مرحبا بك سيد يوليو الى اين ستتجه هذه
الازمه في ضوء تسارع التجارب همم
الصاروخيه الكوريه الشماليه والان الامر
بزياده انتاج الرؤوس النوويه والصواريخ
والرد الكوري الجنوبي عليه
ولد
الامريكيه
بكل وضوح ان اختبارات الصواريخ البالستيه
هذه لا تشكل وتهديدا للولايات المتحده اذا
هنا
تصميمات من الجانب الامريكي
التهديدات
الكوريه الشماليه وفيما يتعلق بالمظله
النوويه الامريكيه التي توفر الحمايه
لحلفاء امريكا بالطبع لدينا حكومه محافظه
في كوريا الجنوبيه من جهه وكوريا الشماليه
اطلقت اكبر عدد من الصواريخ في العام
المنصرم والان القرين الجنوبيين يبحثون
قتل فوائد
واحتمالات
حصولهم على سلاح النووي هم ايضا لهذا
السبب التوتر في المنطقه موجود ومتصاعد
وفي ما يتعلق بسلاح النووي والرابع النووي
لكن حاليا الولايات المتحده تحاول
اطمئنه حلفائها
بالتوفيره او الحماله الامريكيه لكن طبعا
اذا ما تغيرت الامور
وجاء الرئيس جمهوريه يشبه الدوله ترامب
طبعا هذا قد يعني تنازلات من الحلفاء ايضا
يعني انت تتوقع ان يكون هناك سباق
تسلح بين الكوريتين سباق تسلح همم نووي
طيب الان مع وجود سلاح نووي في كوريا
الشماليه ما فائده زياده هذه الرؤوس هويه
كما امر الزعيم الكوري الشمالي ماذا
تستفيد كوريا الشماليه من ذلك
وسائل الضغط اضافيه
للابتزاز والضغط والحصول على تنازلات من
الولايات المتحده ومن
جيرانهم في المنطقه اللي يعود الى مائده
التفاوض بحيث يتم في النهايه رافعه بعض
العقوبات التي تسببت بمصاعب
جمهوري لكوريا
طبعا مثل هذا الامر ربما من المحتمل ان
يحدث لكن في ضوء سباق التسلق حقيقه قد بدا
من قبل في المنطقه وموجود حاليا على مستوى
امتلاك الصواريخ على مستوى المسيارات
وايضا لو ان الضمانات النوويه الامريكيه
والحمايه المعروضه تكون محل شكر لكلفتها
العاليه هذا ربما من شانه ان يجعل كفه
التوازن تميل بالاتجاه الاخر
الدوليه المختص بشؤون الاسيويه في جامعه
اوكسفورد حدثنا من روما شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
نقل مراسل الجزيره في افغانستان عن مصدر
حكوميا قوله ان 14 شخصا قتلوا واصيب 18 في
تفجير بواسطه دراجه ناريه عند المدخل
الرئيسي للمطار العسكري وسط العاصمه كابول
ولم تعلن اي جهه مسؤوليتها عن التفجير
الذي قالت مصادر النيه انه انتحاري
في فقره المتابعه ستكون لنا عوده الى
سلسله التفجيرات في افغانستان
على حركه طالبا
[موسيقى]
اداء الرئيس البرازيلي الجديد
رئيسا للبلاد لفتره جديده عقدت سجنه مده
عام ونصف بسبب تهم فساد اسقطت لاحقا وقد
فاز دا سيلفا في الانتخابات الاخيره بفارق
ضئيل على منافسه الرئيس السابق جرير بونسو
الذي غاب عن مراسم تنصيب في سابقه غير
معوده في البلاد
وهذه صور
المباشره
لتلقي اييي ده سيلفا التهاني بتنصيبه
رئيسا جديدا للبرازيل
قالت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل فوندر
لاين انضمام كرواتيا لمنطقتي شنغن واليورو
يمثل يوما تاريخيا وشهاده على رحله
كرواتيا من اجل الاستقلال والانضمام
لاوروبا
الاول من يوليو 2013 انضمت كرواتيا
للاتحاد الاوروبي لكن بدا من الاول من
يناير 2023 سترفع للمره الاولى الحواجز
على الحدود البريه والبحريه والسكك
الحديديه الداخليه بينها وبين دول منطقه
شنغن على ان ترفع الحواجز الجويه الداخليه
في ال 26 من مارس المقبل وذلك وفق بيان
الحكومه الكرواتيه التحول يشمل ايضا
التخلي عن العمله الكرواتيه المحليه كونا
لصالح اليوم وسيجر التبادل بين العمتين في
البنوك الكرواتيه مجانا حتى نهايه العام
موقعه اتفاقيه شنغن عام 1985 وبدا سريانها
عام
1995 تضم منطقه 26 بلدا بينها اربع دول من
خارج الاتحاد الاوروبي يتعين اجمعها
بالكامل على انضمام اي دوله جديده ويعيش
في هذه المنطقه نحو اربع مئه مليون شخص
ويصل طول حدود المنطقه الخارجيه 50,000
كلم ويتوقع ان يسهم انضمام كرواتيا الى
فضاء شنغن واليورو في تحسين اقتصاد البلاد
وان يزيد قدرتها التنفسيه بفضل تداول
المجانيه والاسرع والارخص للسلع والخدمات
بين الدول الاعضاء كما سيفر الدعم لقطاعها
السياحي الذي يمثل 20% من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نعود الى موضوع التفجيرات التي
تهز مناطق مختلفه من افغانستان من وقت
لاخر واستمرت مع عوده حركه الطالبان لحكم
البلد في صيف عام
وتستهدف هذه التفجيرات في الغالب الاقليات
والمساجد والمنى التحتيه ففي شهر سبتمبر
من العام الماضي عند تفجير هز مسجد وزير
اكبر خان فيلم طاقه الخضراء بالعاصمه
الافغانيه الى مقتل 19 شخصا واصابه 42 في
هجوم
الانتحاري على مركز دراسيا خاصا في كابول
عن مقتل 50 شخصا على الاقل معظمهم من
الطالبات
في مجمع وزاره الداخليه
الافغانيه في العاصمه كابول بالتزامن مع
اداء مسؤولين صلاه الظهر فيه
وفي نوفمبر من العام ذاته سقط عشرات القتل
والجرحى في ثلاثه تفجيرات استضاف احدها
مدرسه في سمنكان بشمالي البلاد واستلف
تفجير بعبوه الناسفه حافله تقل موظفين
حكوميين غربي العاصمه الافغانيه كابول في
حين قتل مدنيون واصيب موظفون امنيون في
هجوم مسلح بمنطقتهارات غربيه البلاد اما
في شهر ديسمبر الماضي
فاسفره هجوم
رجال اعمال صينيون في العاصمه الافغانيه
عن مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص
واصابه 18 اخرين واعلنت الحكومه الافغانيه
حينها عن مقتل المهاجمي
يشكل تصاعد هذه الهجمات التي تبنى معظمها
او تبنى معظمها تنظيم الدوله يشكل التحديا
لسلطه طالبان واختبارا لقدرتها على بسط
الاستقرار في عموم افغانستان فقد وعدت
الحركه بعد عودتها الى الحكم بضمان امن
البلاد بعد عقود من الحرب وهنا
يربط مراقبون بين ارتفاع وتيره العمليات
الدميه في افغانستان وموقف ما يعرف بتنظيم
الدوله في خراسان من حركه طالبان التي
ينتقد رؤيتها للحكم الاسلامي
يقولوا محللون امريكيون ان محاولات
التنظيم لاستقدام مقاتلين ومنافسه طالبان
على النفوذ في افغانستان تتواصل خلال
الفتره القادمه ومع ان العدد الاجمالي
لمقاتلي التنظيم تراجع في السنوات الاخيره
يلاحظ مختصون عوده خلاياه نائمه في
افغانستان النشاط مع انشائه خلايا اخرى في
دول مجاوره ينضم الينا من كابل الدكتور
حمزه مؤمن حكيمي استاذ القانون والعلوم
السياسيه بجامعه سلام مرحبا بك دكتور حمزه
هذه التفجيرات اولا يعني اا عدد الى
افغانستان وعمليا لم تتمكن طيبان من وقتها
او الحد منها لماذا
تحياتي لكم مساء الخير لكم الاستاذ
المشاهدين الكرام
مدينه التفجيرات بدات تتصاعد في الاونه
الاخيره وايضا هناك يعني تطور نوعي في هذه
التفجيرات ايضا كما تحدثت في المقدمه في
البدايه كانت تفجيرات تستهدف دول العباده
والمساجد والاقليات ومراكز الدراسيه لكن
بعد ذلك تطور الاستهداف في السفاره
الروسيه واستهدف السفاره الباكستانيه
والفندق الصينيون وبعد ذلك يعني تطور الى
تفجيرات داخل المناطق امنيه كم داخل مبنى
وزاره الداخليه والان والمطار العسكري
الذي يعني تتبع وزاره الدفاع في همم حكومه
الطالبان وهذه المنطقه شديده همم الحساسيه
وشديده يعني امنيه بشده ولكن همم يعني
وتيره التفجيرات وصلت لهذه المناطق ايضا
وهذا يشير همم يعني الى عدم همم سيطره همم
الامنيه للطالبان بشكل كامل على كل البلد
لانها تفقد الاجهزه الامنيه همم التي
تمتلكها الدول والتي تستطيع من خلالها
السيطره الامنيه الكامله على كل انحاء
البلد في البدايه همم يعني كانوا
المسؤولون في طالبان يقولون يدرون انهم لا
يستطيعون يؤمنوا كل المناطق همم البدنيه
والمساجد وغيرها اما الان فهذه التفجيرات
قد بدات تصل الى اماكن حساسه امنيه وزاره
الدفاع وزاره الداخليه وغيرها من المناطق
الحساسه
فوثيره هذه التفجيرات همم يعني تثير كثيرا
من همم الاسئله حول الامكانيه الطالبان
وقدره الطالبان على اساء الامن والاستقرار
داخل افغانستان وتامين منشات حساسه
الاسئله
في المقابل عن همم قدره تنظيم الدوله الذي
همم يتبنى معظم هذه التفجي على مواصله هذه
التفجيرات وايضا تساؤلات عن اهدافه ما هي
الاهداف التي يحققها من وراء هذه
التفجيرات
نعم نعم
ولكن لابد ان لا ننسى ان بجانب التنظيم
الدوله هناك جهاد عديده اخرى تريد طالبان
ان تفشل في حكمها في افغانستان التنظيم
الدوله ربما تكون الاشرس من هذه الجهات
لكن هناك جبهه المقاومه هناك يعني مخابرات
المنطقه دول مجاوره ايضا لا تريد ان تكون
هناك استقرار في افغانستان يكون هناك
استقرار في افغانستان تضرب في الامن
والاستقرار لكن همم تنظيم الدوله عاده هو
الذي يعلن عن مسؤولياتها عن هذه التبجيلا
ولكن هناك تفجيرات لم تعلن لم يعلن الان
اي جهه لم تعلن اي جهه الى المسؤوليه يعني
هذه التفجيرات همم تنظيم الدوله حقيقه
موجوده في افغانستان وكانت موجوده في ظل
الوجود الامريكي في افغانستان 2017 كانت
هناك يعني معارك طاحنه بين طالبان وتنظيم
الدوله لكن ضعفت هذا التنظيم بعد في طلب
الطالبان عن الحكم وبين
الانسحاب الامريكي لكن كما يبدو الان انه
بدا يعود الى المشهد همم يوم بعد يوم بقوه
وبدات قدراتها همم يعني همم في همم
التفجيرات والاستهدافات تنمو يوم من بعد
يوم شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور حمزه حكيمي
استاذ القانون والعلوم السياسيه
بجامعه السلام من كابول
مشاهدينا بهذا
ناتي الى ختام الحصاد نشكر متابعتك